political instability is making people
ill that's the warning from those
working on the front line of Northern
Ireland's Mental Health crisis well
people are craving certainty right now I
mean anxiety is fear of the unknown
and there's been a collective anxiety
even from covert and it's a fact in our
young people its effect on families its
affected children it's affecting parents
and it's a fact in our society
six months after Shin fein's election
Victory there's not evolved government
at Stormont the dup boycotting it over
the brexit Border in the Irish sea with
the deadline having come and gone the
Northern Ireland secretary appears to be
stalling for time now I do not have to
call an election immediately I've
listened to the party leaders and I'm
going to talk to them all again next
week but
um I will be calling an election
people long for some stability here but
Power sharing has fueled a cycle of
stop-start politics at the wheels of
government have stopped turning this
time at the worst possible moment during
cost of living energy and Health Care
crises
[Music]
on the streets of Belfast people have
lost faith in politics and see little
Point going in and out of polling booths
a waste of time waste of time gonna
prove nothing it'll change nothing
they're still going to fight with each
other the whole thing is a complete and
other
nonsense in the chase I couldn't tell us
Northern Ireland already has the highest
rate of mental illness in the UK and the
longest waiting lists and it's getting
worse if you had one thing to say to the
politicians in Northern Ireland what
would it be
give us some hope
we need hope
we need stability
and we need leadership
people need strong leadership because it
is in the uncertainty it's in the gray
Zone it's in the lack of clarity the
people are struggling
we need hope
it's a play echoed by many and one that
illustrates the gulf between the people
and the politics David Blevins Sky News
in Belfast